is it possible to make a song using a
banana just an board and read everyday
'banahna inspired by this pretty guy
that committed my loss seeing science I
bet you can make a song out of a banana
you overused piece of God so it's like
challenge accepted I think waiting got a
bunch of bananas
I even froze up so that it can ready
peel back on all the sounds comfortable
the solids that the bananas have to
offer and for the truck I know that a
comment like calling me an overused
piece of gum really comes from a place
of sadness and therefore I want to make
you feel good I want to feel good too so
this show is for you I'm going to
recreate the track by the gorillas
called feel-good ink if you don't have
the track the melody goes something like
this
okay let's get right into it for
percussion we've got some pretty solid
variety this truck being heavily
dependence on the bass line to assist me
with that the Old Faithful my wife's
hair ties a flat if F sharp B B flat G
sharp as much as we've exploited the
banana for all the possible Sansa could
make I still feel like me lacking in a
few departments and since it was
referred to as a used piece of gum I put
a bunch of gum as a wild-card
[Music]
then I chewed chewed filling a definite
childhood fantasy of mine
I took the gum instruments to be
refrigerated for two hours I was excited
to test them out after all that chewing
my favorite ones just broke
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you so much for watching speech
CSUN's
as always it was a lot of fun for me I
heard that you had fine food please give
me suggestions below if you would like
me to recreate such a tournament objects
and also feel free to throw an insult in
it if need be if you feel like you don't
need to vent or you need somebody to
absorb some of that sadness throw it my
way
I could call many things and also help
me make music out of New York Texas
society oh yeah and please subscribe
it's just a simple click of a button
also put your notifications well on
other than that
don't forget your awesome booth and I'll
see you next week
[Music]
[Music]